what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
all right what's going on guys this is
Rob and we're gonna try something a
little bit different today
typically we kind of reserved this day
for like beyond omega-level usually it's
around Saturdays
normally it's Friday but you know we
already have a video coming out on
Friday so today we're gonna try things a
little bit different we're running a
little low on like Omega Beyond Omega
level characters I mean in truth for the
last few weeks or so we've just kind of
been grabbing powerful characters and
just throwing them into that category
but if we're gonna stay true to the
concept of Omega and beyond Omega level
then we're gonna have to be a little
more picky about who it is that we allow
into that category so in order to also
offer an emphasis on characters who are
exceedingly powerful but aren't really
qualified or quantified as being like
Omega or beyond Omega level meaning they
haven't been stated to be like planetary
threats or Universal level threats we're
gonna have one a series called origins
and powers and that's all it's gonna be
it's gonna be a character's origins and
their powers and nothing else so I'm
kind of curious to see how this turns
out but because of the fact that Justice
League came out this weekend and because
of the fact that there's really no other
time to talk about it except for the
weekend that justice Lee comes out we
are going to be covering the character
of Steppenwolf now because of the fact
that we've already done a video called
Steppenwolf explain this is gonna be
more of like a stripped-down version of
that whole video but in order to
understand the origin of his character
we first have to delve a little bit into
the history of the comic book industry
now if you're at all familiar with the
history of comics you've undoubtedly
heard of a guy named Jack Kirby and if
you haven't he's widely regarded as one
of if not the most influential figure in
comic books but Jack Kirby is known for
his work at Marvel Comics where he
co-created almost all of Marvel's most
popular superheroes including Captain
America back in the 1940s B Incredible
Hulk Thor Iron Man the Fantastic Four
the x-men daredevil Silver Surfer Black
Panther and the list goes on and on and
on now Kirby will continue to work for
Marvel primarily as an artist throughout
the 1960's alongside his longtime
collaborator Stan Lee but eventually the
professional relationship between Lee
and Kirby became strained which along
with other factors prompted Kirby to
seek out other sources of employment and
move to DC kind of like what Brian
Michael Bendis recently did now as part
of the contract he signed with DC in
1970 Kirby was granted a great deal more
creative freedom than he had enjoyed at
Marvel and was allowed to write the
titles that he was working on instead of
just drawing them and for the most part
Kirby would focus mainly on creating new
characters instead of taking over books
that starred established characters and
one of the more popular Kirby creations
at DC was a group known as the New Gods
which first appeared in their
self-titled solo series in February of
1971 now the new gods were a race of
deities that lived on two planets
brought about by the destruction of the
planet arrghh runned several thousand
years ago these two planets were New
Genesis which was basically a utopian
planet that was ruled by the leader of
the new gods named highfather
and apocalypse which was a dystopian
wasteland ruled by the supervillain
Darkseid who's actually the nephew of
Steppenwolf in DC Comics now Steppenwolf
made his debut in New Gods number seven
and we learned that his sister Hera is
the mother of uc's ass who would
eventually become Darkseid
but because Steppenwolf is such an
obscure character there isn't a ton that
we know about his origin apart from the
fact that he is one of the evil new gods
that lives on apocalypse that's pretty
much his origin but as really all there
is to it he's it's so weird they threw
him in Justice League he was awesome in
Justice League but he's also still
really obscure but there are a couple of
notable things that we do learn about
Steppenwolf from his early appearances
first we know that Steppenwolf was the
leader of the army of Apocalypse and
participated in darkseid's invasion of
New Genesis the other thing we know is
that Steppenwolf was responsible for the
death of a via the wife of Isaiah also
known as high father during that
invasion
although this appeared to be inadvertent
now as far as Steppenwolf origin in the
new 52 reboot of DC Comics we actually
know even less really the earliest we
see Steppenwolf isn't an issue of Geoff
Johns Justice League run where he's on
apocalypse helping Darkseid torture
Superman so we know that he's a follower
of Darkseid in the new 52 continuity
just like he was in the pre flashpoint
continuity the other appearance that we
have is during the story arc earth to
really the line of comics called earth -
when Steppenwolf led an invasion of the
earth - alternate universe in the DC
Comics and basically led to the deaths
of Batman Superman and Wonder Woman I
mean he killed Wonder Woman he killed
Superman I'm pretty sure and then Batman
blew himself up trying to stop
Steppenwolf so so much for the world's
greatest detective but now that we've
covered what we know about Steppenwolf
origin we're gonna move on to his powers
which were actually a little more
interesting now as a member of
New Gods Steppenwolf has a variety of
powers granted to him by his divine
physiology and by and large these are
pretty standard powers amongst
superheroes in the Sin City has
superhuman strength and stamina and
speed and reflexes and so on and so
forth he's immune to all known diseases
and poisons and he doesn't age rendering
him effectively immortal
unless he's killed by a more powerful
force so I guess he's only a mortal
outside of like somebody killing him but
he's also able to produce a Radeon bolt
which is the method that he used to kill
hi father's wife now in addition to this
he is an extremely skilled military
strategist and tactician and expert in
combat with a variety of weapons
including a signature electro axe as
well as hand-to-hand combat and that's
pretty much all that we know about
Steppenwolf powers or at least as far as
I could find there just isn't enough
information about him at this point in
time which may be why they picked him as
the villain for the Justice League movie
because he gives them basically a blank
slate to work with and kind of do
whatever it is that they want to do
about his character without anybody
really complaining about it because you
know I mean it's Steppenwolf as long as
he gets beat up nobody cares what
happens so it's kind of interesting when
it comes to that whole thing but again
this is a really really really short
video it's designed to be stripped-down
it's designed to be small just origins
and powers and I like this so I think
we're gonna keep this as a running
serious but regardless if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like if you are new here to come this
explain make sure you hit the sub button
to become part of the Rob core and I set
those two things backwards um alright
we're gonna try this again but with that
being said guys we're gonna go ahead and
bring this video to an end Gordon do not
take this part out Gordon is my editor
but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to in him if you
are new here to come this explained it
if you are new here to come this
explained make sure you hit the sub
button to become part of the Rob core if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and yeah I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]